hello and welcome to the Nature
Publishing group's journal pub today
we'll be talking about the
global-warming slowdown which you might
also know as the hiatus my name is
Alicia Newton and I'm coming to you from
Nature Geoscience joining me today are
ed Hawkins of getting University Karen
and George Mason and Lisa Goddard of
Columbia University International
Research Institute for climate change
sorry for climate and society joining me
off-screen is from I mean for climate
change and she'll be meeting any live
questions that we get and if you want to
ask any questions yourself let's go to
our Google+ event page or also use the
hashtag and qgj club so hashtag npg j
CLE so right now I'm just going to ask
the panelists to introduce themselves
really quickly starting with Ed so my
name's ed Hawkins I'm a physical climate
scientist at the University of Reading
I've got my research interest in
understanding of the climate system
climate change of climate variability
and also how we visualize this and how
we communicated and widely moving on she
Karen hi as Lisa said my name is Karen
Akerlof and with the Center for climate
change communication at George Mason
University
I've studied media coverage of climate
models and also factors that influence
public public opinion on climate change
and I think at the crux of the things
we're going to be discussing today is
what how climate science communication
affects public attitudes I'm really
looking forward to this conversation
okay thanks and hi my name is Lisa
Goddard I'm the director of
international research institute for
climate in society at Earth Institute
Columbia University I'm also the senior
research scientist and our work that the
IRI
is related to developing climate
information and studying excuse applying
it to the benefit of society my own
personal research interests are in
climate variability and predictability
on seasonal to decade-old timescale hey
I'm actually going to jump right in the
questions and I'm gonna get a view first
right actually
and I'm just hoping you could tell us a
little bit when we say the global
warming slow down or the hiatus or the
warming Klaus um what do we mean what
are we talking about in terms of time so
what we've seen over the last 10 15
years or so is that global temperatures
have not risen as fast as the previous
few decades we have pretty good
observations below the temperature going
back to about 1850 and over that time
we've seen global temperatures rise by
about 8 degrees Celsius the last decade
the climate is not watered as much as
the previous decade probably the
previous few decades and so
understanding that is a very interesting
scientific problem we so understand that
the climate system has these natural
fluctuations the climate is not changing
uniformly or smoothly with time or in
space it has these fluctuations it will
warm at different rates at different
times and we've understood this for a
very long time great and they just
wanted to clarify one time we are
talking about global mean surface
temperatures so much that's right so the
pause has been in the global surface air
temperatures we also have observations
in the ocean and the oceans continue to
warm over that time and but the focus
for this discussion I believe is going
to be the global surface air temperature
and I mean that note we've actually had
a few questions come in so I'm gonna let
Rodman speak for a second you had a
question come in earlier on Facebook
then you pointed out was the degree to
which surface warming has flattened
buried by the data that use and another
question on Google+ where David has
asked where there's a couch and my
assessment of akhi temperatures and
eliminated the pause entirely but Lisa
we're going to throw this one to you and
how large the variation between the
greatest
and it's a warming flow down discernible
and all of them um in terms of the
surface temperatures I say that the
slowdown is consistent in all the
temperature records it does vary there
are uncertainties in the observational
data sets because we don't have
observations everywhere in the world and
some datasets will include more or less
of the reporting stations and then how
we deal with filling in the gaps where
we don't have observations is certainly
a challenge I think there was part of
the question related to when you start
looking at this period of slowdown and
that's certainly an issue as well I know
that in some of the analyses including
the IPCC the the start of what they're
calling this slowdown in globally
averaged temperatures is is marked at
1998 which was the largest El Nino event
on record and we know that these El Nino
events which is described by a warming
of the tropical Pacific sea surface
temperatures when we have these El Nino
events it does definitely impact the
global average temperatures and so you
start with this very large El Nino event
it has a mark on globally average
temperatures and that's just part of
natural variability so if you are
starting there which was already just a
record warm year to that date with
climate change and natural variability
then going forward
the slowdown looks even more marked than
if you would have started after the
oligo event thanks um so it's Karen
we're wondering how has the media been
covering this I guess through the
research in the recording of this hate
of your cause so it clearly the the the
emphasis has been on the pause when the
the IPCC report um was first leaked and
then and then that as a report as people
were publishing on the report the cause
became the focus for a lot of the media
and I think that that's one of the
there's a really need to think about is
that sometimes this is really more about
headlines and newspapers interest in
essentially selling newspapers or
broadcast media's interest in attacking
eyeballs and even online and so
obviously the there were there were
pieces of the IPCC which were available
to people when it was leaked originally
which had wording which of which has
eventually changed which was highly
suggestive of the angle that essentially
the press took it and so that's I think
one of the the huge factors is
essentially the interests of the media
obviously are not necessarily the same
as that of climate scientists and their
ability to convey the the type of detail
that we're hearing today thanks Karen
Lisa you spoke a little bit about El
Nino and natural variability but what
exactly do we know about the causes of
the slowdown and I know on Google+ we
have Dinah asking what is the role of
the oceans so the oceans definitely play
a role in mediating the exchange of heat
between the surface especially the
surface ocean and the deeper parts of
the ocean and so we might be putting
heat into the ocean warming the ocean
more a depth that at the surface and we
have seen in in model simulations as
well as observations that Penney's quote
hiatus periods when the surfaced ocean
is warming less the deep oceans are
warming more and vice-versa we also have
acceleration periods where the surface
ocean is warming more and the the deep
oceans are warming less so an important
part of the mean circulation of the
ocean are these overturning circulation
as a density driven and the density of
the ocean is dependent on both
temperature and salinity but as you as
you change the rate of either bringing
heat down into the ocean or not bringing
as much cold water down into the ocean
both of those things lead to a relative
warming of the deep ocean and
variability such as Pacific decadal
variability which is related to ENSO
also sea
to have an impact on this sort of
overturning circulation in the Pacific
that can impact temperatures on year to
year basis and decade to decade basis
great um and I know we've seen a little
bit also about volcanoes or the Sun Edie
do you have anything so yeah as Lisa
says there the climate undergoes these
natural fluctuations which we've seen
for a very long time in the simulations
and in the observations but also very
important I think for the for the last
ten or fifteen years or so is the the
forcings which drive by the climate we
want to be well aware of greenhouse
gases which help warm the climate but
they're also factors which help cool the
climate and some of these include
volcanic eruptions and so we have seen
us more a few small volcanic eruptions
over the last ten years or so which act
the cool climate we've also seen the Sun
move into a less active phase and
receiving slightly less energy from the
Sun over the last decade that we've
might expected it's in this relatively
cool and quiet phase and so again that
lactis look to take the edge off
temperatures and so actors are cooling
influence on temperatures so we're
seeing this balancing act between
factors that have warmer climate and
factors have cooler climate at the
moment they seem to be sort of in
balance we have the variability and the
volcanoes and solar cycle acting cooler
climate as well as the greenhouse gases
and so on helping to warm the climate at
the moment it's a balancing act but
these volcanic like kind of corruptions
and solar cycle variations a fairly
temporary so I think when when when they
subside and then again okay thanks
so we've talked about a lot of different
factors and usually each of these
factors is reported in a different study
so and then the media then reports that
one study at a time Karen do you think
that this sort of slow drip of climate
information has an impact on how people
understand the climate as a whole
can you hear me now apologize there are
a couple of factors that I think are
important to take into consideration so
number one is that as I mentioned the
factors in terms of media and their
interests and how they publicize a story
so I mean I think the really the message
with the IPCC release became the pause
which lets so we should probably
interpret that for a lot of people
really meant that global warming is
stopped so not that we're hearing is
about the discussion of the variability
and that this overall trend is going up
but really the way the media has
portrayed it and obviously especially
skeptical media has portrayed it is
essentially the models were wrong and
that means that climate science does not
have the ability to essentially describe
to us what future conditions are going
to be like which obviously is also too
severe implications to what we do or do
not do in terms of policy and so I think
number one we have to think this is how
that how did the media then use the
pause to communicate about the results
from the IPCC report which is supposed
to be this landmark statement of
certainty we really know what's going on
and instead it became a landmark
statement of uncertainty that we really
don't know and obviously that's that's a
really critical point when especially in
the United States we had I think CBS
flood with the news of the IPCC being
the pause not the certainty so we're
talking about mainstream media picking
this up and and obviously the Economist
was also one that communicate a lot in
this issue so number one this is a media
phenomenon more broadly about how do we
talk about climate change that it has a
lot of import to policy and the other
one is I think what we're looking at too
is essentially the IPCC reports are
being leaked before the actual release
and so the words in them are not
necessarily what they are in the final
report and that's being used the leaks
are being used on both sides so they're
being used to push policy in both
directions and there is a result you
have this interesting policy dynamic or
political dynamic that is occurring
around the release of these reports
which really isn't anything particularly
about climate science it's really about
policy and the way these things are
being spun
and so I think that's another element of
this which really by the time that
something like this comes out in terms
of the pause people and it's being
communicated in these very politicized
ways people's ability to actually begin
to think in a neutral atmosphere about
the climate science itself and what's
the science indicates when weather
becomes very very difficult because
essentially we're already talking about
the science within these very
politicized contexts which have doomed
it aside is essentially defined as
either climate change is occurring or
essentially it's a hoax and so I think
unfortunately that makes it really
difficult for scientists to actually
begin to have a conversation about all
these different factors that we're
talking about so ed I guess this leads
really nicely to you as you discuss a
lot of this and social media and media
could you comment about your experiences
there has anything been particularly
successful disastrous yes I think as
scientists we must get used to I think
being open more transparent and
communicating our science openly for
example through blogging which I do a
lot of as do many others and tweeting
and so on and that has been particularly
useful I think to help communicate the
various complex issues around the cause
and so now I think we just need to get
used to being a bit more transparent and
communicating better and visualizing
things better I think one of the key
issues has been that when the IPCC or
many representations of what's going to
happen over the next 50 or a hundred
years or so we've tended to smooth out
these variations their climate is
presented nice smooth projections of
what's going to happen in the future and
we've kind of not included the ups and
downs that you know we're carrying the
observations also carrying out
simulations we kind of haven't displayed
them I think it's it's it's it's
hindered our communication is that we
haven't displayed those ups and downs
and that we see and and so I think that
we need to speed will open and better
the way we communicate and visualize our
science and what will happen in the
future okay I think Lisa wanted to add
to that yeah I didn't think those are
both excellent points I think that also
we're and the general public is just
asking much more out of the IPCC out of
these climate change projections than
they're really intended to deliver so
whereas those model experiments and
those projections are intended to tell
us how the climate system as a whole is
responding to increase in greenhouse
gases changes in external forcing we're
now the general public and the media is
looking to that information to really
and expecting it to give them a forecast
so if the next few years or the next
decade doesn't play out according to
their expectations of that response to
greenhouse gases then it's it seemed
that that set of models isn't doing
their job when in fact the models do
have those those modes of variability in
them but that's just not what they're
designed to provide information on there
those are not predictions
they're projections and so they are
providing useful information say on how
the the baseline of climate how the mean
climate is changing underneath this
variability so we can use it to provide
information on changing risks for
example the changing risk of extremes or
the changing risk of drought
even if that variability itself doesn't
change as a result of climate change so
that's useful information but it's not
it's not a prediction it's not designed
to tell us what's going to happen it in
its exact evolution over the next ten
years okay I think Karen you wanted to
add something oh sorry your microphone
again I apologize I wanted to pick up on
what ed was saying is actually some
there's some really nice social science
that in both the weather realm and just
recently in the climate change realm
that shows that actually that people do
you trust information more if it's an
area like weather for example and you
give them an error bar and sort of what
the range of expectations is they're
more likely to trust that information
than if you give them a data point
because they have a natural
understanding of there is
certain amount of variability in that
system and and they actually do
intuitively um trust information like
that better
and just recently a study out of
Stanford again with sea level rise is
very similar phenomenon so people are
more likely to trust information when
you give them that range of variability
then you just give them one number so
exactly what he's saying
um it's very much on point okay thank
you tonight actually over to Ed for a
second and ask you what might be a kind
of hard question that's do we know how
long the pause might actually last I
think that's a key question isn't it and
we we don't know how long it will last
and we suspect that it comes down to
what is causing the pause and we haven't
yet quantified in detail the fraction
say of the pause which is due to the
volcanic eruptions in the solar
influence they're certainly having some
role how much of a role are they playing
and how much is due to variability we
have we need to have a better handle on
that we had to understand when we might
return to a rated having said that I
think there's a it's looking likely
there might well be an El Nino this year
the indications are in the Pacific
Pacific may well going to Nell Nino
phase this year which means we should
see temperatures increase and as a
result of that but we're not yet at the
stage where we can predict exactly when
we will emerge and from the hiatus and
or the slowdown but we can be confident
that we will return to the trend once
these temporary cooling and factors
subside
we mentioned going to an El Nino and
earlier at Lisa mentioned that the 98 El
Nino was this huge warming and a step
change would that could that cause
something like that step change again if
we go into a strong El Nino sorry yes
yeah we would expect to see and it
depends how big the only news for
starters and if it's a very big El Nino
then we expect to see temperatures and
be very warm for a year or two and after
that
thanks Lisa I might have another hard
question for you this time but do we
have any idea if this sort of pause or
slowdown has had any effect on sort of
this society relevant climate impacts
like sea-level rise extreme events or
regional precipitation well we are still
seeing extreme events in particular
there the increases in say extreme heat
days very hot days has continued
worldwide but like with any climate
variability so the the extent that the
decadal variability is playing a role in
this hiatus so we can say that those are
linked decadal variability will change
the atmospheric circulation so it will
change the regional climate many believe
that the changes in ocean temperatures
in the Pacific and the Atlantic are both
in playing a large role in the drought
that the western United States has been
experiencing that it may also be playing
a role in some of the conditions in
Southeast Asia over the last few years
but any particular any particular
climate event unless you actually gone
through a very diagnostic study is
difficult to tie down would it have
happened without this particular pattern
of variability thanks an IDI here to
comment yeah just just to add on what I
said earlier I think it's important to
note that and from our measurements from
space from satellites and so on we can
measure that the earth is still
absorbing more energy than its giving
out so if the earth was in balance then
we would receive and give out a safe
amount of energy what we can see is that
currently we are thinking more of an
evening out which means it is warming up
and there may not be expressed in the
surface air temperature but that means
that they must be going into the ocean
and so that balance and normally we as I
say would expect to give at 365 days of
sunlight the year but in fact we're
keeping about half a day of summer
oh yeah and rather than leaving it back
out first the system is not in balance
and we can measure that the some degree
of accuracy so we can be confident the
earth is still warming up it just isn't
expressed in the surface air temperature
at the moment okay thanks um Karen had a
question for you
number to go from you at this time so I
had a question for ED and Lisa actually
so in terms of the things you're
describing especially what ed is
describing so the system is still
absorbing heat even if you're not
necessarily seeing massive differences
in temperature surface temperature
trends what what would what are the
terms that you would use to describe
what's going on would you use the term
hiatus would you use the term pause or
are there other terms that you think are
actually more accurate to describe
what's going on right now I think it's a
very difficult question I think
somebody's these words we have very
different meanings to different people I
think that's that's part of the part of
the problem and pause and slowly slow
down is probably the most accurate
potentially because we we are still
seeing temperatures increase it's just
the rate of change is slowed down and so
I prefer that pause has often been used
in more in the media and as if it's
pausing and then will resume again and
these words have different meanings for
different people so there's anybody talk
to that yeah I think that my my
difficulty with the terminology in
general is it really puts almost all the
emphasis on the climate change part of
it and what we're actually experiencing
is is climate on all timescales so the
the fact that the this increase in heat
that the earth is absorbing that Ed
Keith has referred to that that is
ongoing and it's been ongoing it's going
to keep going but on top of that we have
these natural cycles year to year in
decade to decade that also have a
temperature signature globally and
regionally and so our experience of that
especially in a local setting is the
combination of all of these things and
so I think having a broader appreciation
for all of the factors that result in
the climate we experience leads to the
perhaps a better way to discuss and
describe what it is that's going on so
couple so climate change hiatus I think
is very misleading because it really
puts it all on the anthropogenic part
which I don't think is having any hiatus
thanks Karen I might actually turn that
back to you and do you think that the
terminology used has an impact on how
the public sees or perceives I am
definitely I mean I think the problem
being so Joe Rahm at climate progress
did a summary of the headlines that were
used when the Act CC came out and I
think the takeaway message when you see
one sentence or even three words is that
essentially this is an issue that if
it's not it is a decreased importance
just crease concern and particularly
when the message is paired with an
explanation that that it's not well
explained even though we have some some
explanations it's not well explained by
the models that we had and so it makes
it looks like the science is more
uncertain than perhaps it is for climate
change as a whole so so yeah I think
that's it's unfortunately it's heavily
reductionist and I think what you're
even seeing now even as this issue has
sort of died and just to quickly point
out I did that quick Google Trends
search to see where our global warming
pause is right now um which was in a
number of the nature climate change
articles in the United States it looks
like this month month the issue has
pretty much died so it's back down to
where it was in August 2013 so in some
ways that actually may be a good thing
because obviously the emphasis really
was on how this seems to be
counterintuitive from what we've been
saying for a long time okay thanks and
we've actually got a live question to
read from Bronwyn we've had a question
coming in on Google+ from state he's
asked does it make sense to publicly
highlight that the earth energy to
highlight the Earth's energy imbalance
more strongly than has
we've been done so that isn't the earth
is absorbing more energy than it is
radiating back to space don't know ed
well yeah that's kind of the point I was
trying to make just now perhaps is that
now that we have very good satellite
coverage we can look at the energy
balance as a whole and see that less
radiation is doing that space than we
are receiving in from the Sun and so
that that means the system is out of
balance which means it will warm up so
that it's at least some emphasis that we
need to present but it's also true to
say that we've the cold we've got the
longest records of surface air
temperature that's this iconic image
that we've always seen and used as a
measure of climate changing and
variability over the last hundred and
fifty years and so that is a very iconic
committee which people have seen a lot
of and expect to see more of and so we
must just dismiss that is very relative
metric but I agree that we need to try
and look at other ways of presenting the
information communicating the fact that
the planet is still warming as a whole
and I think Lisa you had a few more
comments about terminology and how
scientists versus the media communicate
oh um could you unmute yourself so easy
to forget that so just in terms of
responsibility I think that we've been
hanging a lot on the media and the
public in terms of being responsible for
using this terminology I was just doing
it a moment ago saying you know using
the word hiatus is perhaps is perhaps
putting too much on climate change on
the other hand I will say that that
there the scientific community needs to
step up and claim responsibility for
during the period of acceleration so
going from the 70s into the 80s when we
again had natural variability that was
in a warming phase on top of climate
global warming due to man-made causes so
those things are moving together but the
message coming out was that this is
climate change acceleration and a lot of
the scientific community didn't really
have a
problem in lumping things together then
and I think that that's now open open
the scientific community for some attack
in going back to the the realization
that variability and change are
happening at the same time so I think
you know we need to be open about the
mistakes that our communication has made
in the past and try to be more open
going forward great so I might actually
ask Karen maybe and then Edie how do you
put that how what is the back way if we
scientists but that impact so I mean I
think what I would try to say is that I
think that there are different times
when scientists are more likely to be
effective in their communication so so
that sounds like a med does a lot of
blogging and interacts with people
online in in a way that allows for a
give-and-take in a long term
conversation whereas I think when we're
talking about contacts where again I
mean think the the conditions under
which this arose were very highly
politicized they were cherry-picked in a
sense or as the as the report was
launched and there were certain reasons
why this this conversation occurred in
that time and then I think it becomes
actually really difficult for scientists
to have any type of really productive
conversation because essentially what
you're doing then is you're trying to
change the spin and that's really more
about public relations and I think
unfortunately it is heavily in a policy
context and I think that at that point
the skills that are required to begin to
begin to change how that conversations
occurring or maybe not necessarily ones
that that all climate scientists are
going to be able to have some obviously
well but I think it makes it much more
difficult so I mean obviously they're
places like you know like the kind of
things that ads been recommending it
makes a lot of sense to be able to have
those conversations about the nuances
that Lisa is talking about great ed I
don't know if he had anything to add I
think I agree with Karen that we
discussed the nuances
more than we do and blogging twittering
here for example gives you one way of
having those conversations and so I mean
even in the very first IPCC assessment
report which I have a copy of their in
1990 it says that we expect pauses
essentially it says that we will see
pauses it says we see ups and downs in
variability on top of any long term
trend but we seem to have lost that
communication message in the intervening
period and it comes back to Lisa's point
about communicating more openly
we have always expected to see pauses we
just couldn't necessarily put it when
there would happen but we always
expected to see them at some stage and I
think we lost that communication angle
Karen one of the things too we've got
this variability in the climate we offer
variability in public opinion and and I
think one of the things is that the
pause is really people are thinking
about it a little bit in this in concern
to be honest about how Climategate and I
lose that term loosely
well it's how those issues were dealt
with and and the the pairing with the
linking with declines in public opinion
around that time and they were actually
they were actually global because
actually right now especially in the
United States we are actually seeing
declines in public opinion on on climate
change so increases over between April
and November about seven percentage
point increases in the number and
percent of people who think that climate
change is not occurring and specifically
we're seeing is actually these decreases
are people who say they're very very
highly educated about climate change and
so I think the concern is that you know
in really unfortunately is about policy
that especially as people in the United
States are looking to try and find
solutions and in terms of policy
responses public opinion is really
really crucial and how these
conversations occur then in terms of the
climate science feed into people's
perceptions of the necessity for policy
responses thank you
so just looking at the time we're just
about running out but I wanted to ask
each of you before we go if you
could tell me what do you think the
warming hiatus has taught us about
climate change or how we communicate
that climate change to the public
your biggest revelation from this and I
might start with and actually thank you
and so I think the main thing I've
learned from the recent slowdown that
says we have to be more open about how
we communicate we have to talk about the
interesting science that's going on the
subtleties and nuances and communicating
that more openly and more widely and I
think is incredibly important Karen
sorry I would say that I think we need
to be prepared that these are constantly
gonna be having conversations that we're
going to have and then it's going to be
difficult for the public to understand
and need to figure out ways to have
these conversations better okay at least
that uh I think that it's really excuse
me I think it's really motivated some
interesting new research into a debt
Cadle variability and climate change and
the models ability to capture those in
the relevant processes behind them great
and with that I'd like to thank everyone
who's tuned in for our journal Club and
participated and of course our lovely
panelists and we hope to see you for the
next and PG journal club thank you